last month both richard branson and jeff
bezos made history
by traveling to space on their own
private vehicles many have argued that
these two didn't actually reach
real space as they didn't reach orbit or
even travel very far
into space though their achievements are
extremely impressive in their own right
i can see why many wouldn't exactly
consider them astronauts
elon musk however is easily capable of
taking off all the boxes of being an
astronaut he's easily capable of using
falcon 9 to not only cross the carmen
line
but reach the iss stay in the isis for
several months and then return safely
despite this though elon has yet to make
the journey
so here's why elon refuses to go to
space
before we jump into the video i wanted
to address that elon will likely go to
space
eventually whether that's next month or
10 years from now what
i don't know but it is likely in
eventuality
so i wanted to make it clear that i'm
not saying that elon will never go
to space rather i simply wanted to take
a look
at why he has refused the opportunity
thus far just by having the technology
for years
with that being said let's jump into the
first and most obvious reason
which is death space travel is not the
safest journey to embark on
and each space flight carries
significant risk for a straight-up death
even with falcon 9 which has proven to
be one of the most reliable rockets of
all time
the risk of death is not negligible nasa
estimates that there's a 1 in 60 chance
that a falcon 9 mission fails but does
not lead to a fatality
and there's a 1 in 276 chance that a
falcon 9 mission fails
and leads to a fatality that's about the
same chance as having twins
elon musk already has twins and triplets
so
maybe that's a sign that he shouldn't
take the trip but putting cosmic signs
aside
death itself is not the real challenge
for eulon the real challenge would be
the consequences that follow his death
spacex and tesla
are by no means mature companies tesla
has recently made strides forward
and is likely at a point where can
survive and even thrive without elon
but just three years ago tesla was
within single-digit weeks of bankruptcy
and tesla may have gotten wiped out
without elon
similarly spacex doesn't really have a
successor lined up
gwen shotwell is amazing and could
probably run the company
as well as elon but gwen is actually
older than elon at 57
so she's not really a long-term
successor considering the current states
of spacex
and tesla it doesn't make sense for elon
to risk the futures of these companies
which is basically his life's work on a
joyride to space but
wait a minute if spacex itself is not a
mature company
there's no way that blue origin and
virtual galactic are mature companies
so why were jeff bezos and richard
branson willing to risk the futures of
their space companies
well the answer is to play catch-up
virgin galactic spaceship 2
has only had a total of 4 space flights
and richard branson rode on the 4th
launch
fortunately all of these space flights
have been successful
but with only 4 total flights you
wouldn't exactly describe spaceship 2
as having a stellar track history blue
origin does have a lot more data
as they launched new shepard a total of
15 times before jeff took his flight
throughout the 15 launches new shepard
had 14 successful flights
and one partially successful flight even
in a partially successful flight
blue origin was able to recover the
capsule successfully so
new shepard has a pretty strong safety
record but
even that holds no water in comparison
to falcon 9.
the demo 2 mission we saw last year with
bob and doug was literally the 85th
launch of the falcon 9.
it would take years for virgin galactic
and blue origin to rival spacex's track
record
at blue origin's current pace of about 1
launch every 3 months
it would take them 17 and a half years
to complete 85 launches
even if blue origin sped up the space
excess pace and did a launch every other
week with new shepard
it would take blue origin another two
and a half years to complete 85 launches
so clearly virgin galactic and blue
origin it needed to catch up
in terms of reliability and one of the
boldest ways to vouch for the
reliability of your spacecraft
is to ride it yourself and that's
precisely what they did
as for elon he does not need to vouch
for the reliability of falcon 9
and he does not need to catch up to
anyone so
elon riding on falcon 9 would do little
for spacex's future
or track record something else we have
to consider is that spacex has a
completely different customer base than
blue origin
and virgin galactic spacex doesn't
really care about the space tourism
market
every time i say this i get comments
asking me if i've ever heard about
spacex's dear moon project
or the upcoming action trip in 2022 the
answer is yes
i have heard about these missions and
spacex does do tourism trips here and
there
but this is by no means their focus the
dear moon project is basically a
fundraiser for starship
and with the axiom trip to the iss
action is the one that's handling the
tourism side of the business
for spacex it's just another commission
to the iss
they're not spending time or effort in
advertising the service and selling
tickets
they're just the vehicle provider spacex
really only deals with commercial
customers and 95 of their missions are
business or science related
so i think it's safe to say that spacex
does not focus on space tourism
for blue origin and virgin galactic
however space tourism is a focal point
they don't really have many commercial
customers and they expect to make the
vast majority of their money by selling
tickets
to space blue origin for instance has
apparently
already sold to nearly 100 million
dollars worth of space tickets
this vastly different customer base
leads to vastly different expectations
neither nasa nor the us military give a
crap about whether elon wrote on falcon
9.
they each have thousands of scientists
working for them and they'll perform
their own risk analysis of falcon 9 to
determine
whether they want to contract out a job
to spacex or not
similarly when companies decide on
whether to use a spacex rocket
they only care about three things
payload capacity
price and the risk of failure again they
don't give a crap about elon riding a
rocket
this space tourism customer base however
values this much more
here's the thing let's say you're a
multi-millionaire worth about 5 million
dollars
and you're considering buying a 250 000
ticket to space with either blue origin
or virgin galactic you can look at the
track record of new shepard
and spaceship 2 but you don't actually
know the physics behind each spacecraft
and the safety of the two seem pretty
similar now
let's say richard branson writes
spaceship 2 to space but jeff bezos does
not ride new shepard
i don't know about you but if i was in
this position i would definitely choose
virgin galactic over blue origin
the reasoning is that richard branson is
much more important than me
and if he's willing to trust his life on
spaceship too then he's probably pretty
darn confident in its safety
as you can see founders wearing their
rocket holds much more weight within the
space tourism industry
than the commercial space industry and
this just further disincentivizes elon
from making the trip
moving on another factor hindering elon
is likely the time commitment
blue origin and virgin galactic's
offerings are specifically designed to
be as
easy to use as possible this means
minimal training
minimal learning and just overall
minimal effort
and this makes sense considering that
the entire trip is only a couple of
minutes
if elon were to write falcon 9 though
the training would be much more
extensive
as in many months the action 1 crew for
instance will undergo 15 weeks of
training before traveling to the iss
in the business world 15 weeks is more
than an entire fiscal quarter
imagine if elon stepped back from tesla
for a full quarter to go train for a
falcon 9 flight
i don't think tesla investors especially
institutional investors and wall street
would be very happy and finally the last
reason that elon may be hesitant in
taking a trip to space
is that he's saving a journey for
something much larger as
jeff bezos said it's not like any of
these guys are actually the first people
to go to space
at this point people have been traveling
to space for over 50 years
and though less than a thousand people
have traveled to space in that time
period
would people even care about jeff bezos
or elon musk going to space if it wasn't
for their popularity
i mean just look at spacex's own crude
missions
everyone knows that bob and doug were
the first ones to ride falcon 9 to the
iss
but do you know the astronauts that were
part of crew 1 or crew 2
considering this would an elon trip
actually be a massive achievement
or would it just be a big thing because
elon is involved i think it's more of
the latter
so maybe elon does not want to go to
space until the trip itself
is historic whether that's a trip around
the moon or a trip to mars
speaking of a trip around the moon a
reporter actually asked elon if you
would be willing to join the japanese
billionaire on the deer moon project
and this is how he responded what does
that make you
think about going to space yourself and
when do you think that's going to happen
you mean like me personally oh uh
well i think first of all like i say
i mean i think this is like
done a lot to restore my faith in
humanity that somebody's willing to do
this
like you know to take their money and
like
help fund this new project that's risky
might not succeed it's dangerous it's
like
donating seats like these are great
things
it's like to tell you something like to
restore my faith humanity
as you can see elon was super hesitant
in answering the question
and he basically just avoided the
question and talked about how usaku
restored his faith in humanity
elon would eventually answer the
question though and here's what he said
and as far as me going i'm not sure
he didn't suggest like maybe that i
would join on this trip
i don't know yeah yeah yeah all right
maybe we'll maybe we'll must be on it
[Applause]
as you can see elon did not technically
refuse to go
but his hesitance makes it seem like
it's quite unlikely due to all the
reasons we already outlined in this
video
with that being said though elon has
also stated that he would be down to die
on mars i mean if you're gonna
at least we're all gonna die someday um
so
if you're gonna die someday i'm like
okay you wanna be better than miles
worth i'm like
mars sounds cool born on earth die on
mars that's uh you know
if you got the choice so maybe that's
been his master plan
all along how do you guys think elon's
first space trip will look like
comment that down below also drop a like
if you can't wait for space to become
affordable for us mortals
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm ari and i'll see you guys on the
next one